hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play haunted
memories now if you recall back last
year the age when Slender games were
exploding and everyone was making him
and everyone had wanted to part with it
one game stood out among them to me
which was slender haunt and now this
game is a reimagining of what the
universe that he was creating in a
progression of series of chapters so as
you can see there are multiple episodes
that will be available in the future but
for now the first one is just here for
free where did he pretty go there it is
okay so and as you recall Slender
haunted some of the best graphics some
of the best um some of the best
implementation of what I thought slender
should be and how he was startling
everyone so I am very excited to be able
to play this again I mean for one I
really enjoyed it and for two it means
more of an awesome indie game because
there's gonna be a full game on the end
of it it's rare but the absolute
whatever I've been blabbering on for a
while about crap you don't care about
this is haunted memories and as you can
see it's really really pretty
oh I'm so excited
I'm always happy to see these indie
games come out in this game is this the
first part anyway is totally free it's
early asking access right now so expect
some bugs but compared to any other
indie game I play I'm sure it'll be just
fine
so now I don't know if this is a direct
copy of the first slender haunt map it
does not seem like it given that intro
sequence that seems familiar though I
mean I'm assuming it's generally gonna
be the same concept but the other
episodes that are gonna be coming out in
the future should be different whew
somebody should be near somebody named
the Slenderman tab to open file project
hon Green Park Power Station objective
adaptation if you are all aware of the
adaptation process is the most important
process during the coast purification
assignment this is why we have chose
I've choose to alter facility 109s
objective lennie to turn down the volume
it's quite loud in my ears either way
okay I got a map and a flashlight how do
I get quickly that's a equip grip
flashlight boom gotta close that I saw
something on the ground I did batteries
almost missed that gonna be hard to see
things with this flashlight we have a
typewriter here markiplier is awesome
create created okay oh that's cool I
guess
nah for remember how the first one
started if you guys haven't seen my
slender haunt playthrough because you're
new subscriber
hi buddy hey friend
you'll know that the Slendy man in this
one is very nice I don't know he seemed
quite different than the first one
though his tentacles weren't as grand
maybe they'll get bigger maybe he's just
warming up and he needs to you know
check it out a little more alright let's
see
yeah the map I'm looking at it now looks
way different from the other one huh God
Oak Avenue seems a bit more contained
the Hill Lost Valley there seems to be
like this road going up the center there
and then pining up let me go up to the
left first oh that is cool
oh this is so cool it's made on the
Unity engine by the way Sam is the first
one I believe is it on the Unity engine
I'm not sure I would think so but either
way it goes to show that people with
real talent can make something very
special they put their minds to it not
everything on the end of the engine has
to be those indie games that you seen I
let me play you you see me do see me me
play game me play game and me you see
okay I hey enough of me intelligence
that's actually really cool I'm looking
at right now I've got actually an arrow
that points where I am on the map which
is incredibly useful because if you
remember in the last one what is that
what is that oh that's just a sign in
them I look to sign in a car I saw it
never mind never mind
okay so I lost my train of thought of
what I was gonna say but whatever just
the lighting in this game is really
really interesting
it opened is it locked is it locked it's
locked
so I can't go in there there seems to be
some restricted areas restrict to a
restricted C and restrict B is the big
one over there they better turn on the
generator didn't read this operations
have ended in success Green Park it
Power Station is ready to receive new
visitors areas secured an outside
disturbance is not a concern okay so I
see this generator on and restrict B
over there I got to get into restrict B
but obviously these places are locked so
I'm gonna need to find some keys before
anything
hello as I recall in the first one off
to the left er there was a building that
got me started out before but I'm
assuming that things are different now
everything's changed things seem
different what is this a big red dildo
no silo something huh wait a minute
you're telling me that the big red dildo
and the first one whose silo no that's a
different game that actually is a
different game it's under the 8 pages is
very different from Flender haunt
thunder haunts is made
I forget the maker of the game but
hopefully it'll be easy this is
available on Steam by the way it was
greenlit by the community which I'm very
happy about go anyway
nothing me blabbering about things you
don't care about let's get into the
nitty-gritty of this let's collect us
some pages hmm is this place locked as
well what what is that barrel blocking
my path oh I wish there was a way around
this barrel oh how I wish there was a
way God okay that barrel is blocking my
path apparently looks like that might
actually be the factory okay that's
respect
eh maybe there is another way it's been
said that someone figured out the oh
it's locked huh oh how I wish I could
get over this Fred's oh how I wish there
was a war I just watch the Brian Regan
that's why I'm quoting him right now oh
how I wish it was the way okay that
seems to be some sort of factory which
means that I'm walking along the
outskirts of restricted a yes restricted
a now where does this go is this just
Lee do hello
as you've probably been able to tell
this game is kind of awesome in the way
it's constructed just the weather the
ambiance for everything it's so awesome
I'm so excited to be playing it again
because there's gonna be so much more
content I mean there has been a serious
lacking and good good indie horror games
I'm not sure if I would count outlast
among the Indians of the indie what is
this living this a cave whoa whoa just a
cave or did I oh no it's not a by just
oh we'll just pretend like that wasn't
there we didn't see into the game we're
not breaking anything over here okay but
it seems like the road does end if I
wanted to get around I might have to go
the other way so we're gonna venture off
into the other side and wait a minute I
see
hey the green in is over on the other
side now that's where I got started in
the first one that's probably where I
should have gone first up sorry but I
was just soaking in the amazing
atmosphere gosh it's so good
ah so good sometimes I just got us
okay nothing sometimes I just got to
stop and appreciate how well-built
the game is and this is nice this is
nice I mean obviously it's early access
please do remember that this is early
access they basically rebuilt the whole
game so if you got some issues with bugs
that you found keep it to yourself or be
constructive Kristen okay
just replace my battery by reloading it
does that make sense no it doesn't make
sense I heard something I hear something
in the woods in the woods in the woods
in the woods is in I didn't find any
pages but then again I didn't look very
hard okay I was so busy taking the
atmosphere I kind of forgot that this
might have maybe have just been a horror
game that I was playing here Oh al fun
times okay it doesn't seem like the map
is as astronomically large as the last
one
this one's on a bus I don't want to go
up into the center area I feel like that
has some sort of finality to it I'm
gonna try to go off to the sides first
and make a loop cuz that's what worked
for me in the first game now also in the
first game there were areas like in this
woods like in here there was something
in here before like the old TV stand
that didn't make any sense for being out
there but then again it's none as big so
hopefully I hear footsteps I wasn't me
that time that was really something I
don't know what it da I found something
in the middle of the woods you know what
was that me or was that the woods hey
whatever I'm freaking myself out more
than anything which is good for the game
bad for me what is that who's out there
it's like they're not even stopping
anymore they're just constantly I'm
getting out of the woods I do not like
the woods I do not like the woods
where's the path where am i I'm almost
to the green end I'm just good I guess
seems to be some sort of a wall blocking
my way a wall of rocks would you call
one of those would you call one of those
hard stone like things that's up and big
I don't know hmm okay let's go to the in
hi more batteries plenty of batteries
hopefully this flashlight is a little
more longevity lies than the first one
actually I don't know I don't recall how
fast the first one ran out of batteries
okay we're at the house so the memories
you've brought forth
Let Me In it's locked
well damn it was it locked before maybe
it was I feel like part of it was locked
like the back door was locked
hey what is that gonna weigh in no okay
can I see inside this building No
they jump I can jump but not enough to
get over there maybe Iran back if I
recall there was something around back
in the last one maybe this time okay
good
all right nothing back there nothing
back there
little piggy no no little piggy go home
make it in here I get in here
can I get in here ah come on blocks
locked dot dot dot well a free in the a
and don't have a nice day
gosh dang it gosh darnit kibbles what am
I supposed to do as a recall I found a
key but it was fairly early on in the
last one I don't know where to go I
don't know what to do I know what to do
Lenny mnsure has been absent I wonder
where he is I don't think he comes
around until I found a few more pages so
I'm worthy of his presence
let me check over here there's just this
little alcove I love all the trees look
likes Lenny's tentacles just jutting out
from the woods like that
hello mr. Schad there seems to be a
series of you Oh what the hell sport it
up anything in there that I need damn it
okay at least my guys controlling his
breathing good I guess I don't see
anything in there that I make ha ha oh I
forgot you were in this game oh hi I see
you over there
ha ha hey how's he always got I blinked
did I get blink it he was gone okay
alright whatever I wasn't even on the
algo was I click I heard a click that
must be whoa what the hell is that just
a son flat no that is something what is
that I don't know what that is must be
part of the center the center thing the
one that goes to
the middle of the valley of the Guanella
what is this
hello what is that I get in here
can I get in there please let me in
Oh what happened oh my god oh wait was
it already open oh well oh yes I'm gonna
assume that I did that with pure skill
is this there's no gas in the fuel tank
what what do you mean my flashlight is
almost dead reload load the batteries
does that even mean how do I get gas in
how do I get gas in that ass sorry my
mouse has been I see it over my second
monitor my mouse is kind of going
outside of the game which is not a good
thing but oh well not a problem there's
been nothing I need to click on anyway
how do I get gas in your ass how do I
get casting you ah ooh where are they
okay all right
he's being a bit more aggressive I'm
sorry I don't know how to get gas and I
blinked any goes away good good well now
I'm just making a circle what is that
over there there's something over there
maybe there's gas up that way oh I love
this I love this I love this I haven't
been able to save for a while though so
I hope I don't die Wow how do we have
here another map I don't really need
these maps cuz I got this one here
that's interactive in mobile but anyway
that is lending up there no that's just
a tree huh is that Slendy no it's just a
tree ah mr. tree oh man who's that up
there at the light of some sort
my what is this what is you what is it
what did I just get what I get
wait hang on by the way how do I do this
F T oh I get it okay okay read fuse fuse
with red emblem oh hey what you know
what that means
I know what that means but I got it
okay good I got it ray good for me what
does that mean I have no idea I have no
idea I honestly have no idea all right
anyway I am going to pick this up
immediately
how is in the ever I'm a lot of time for
now so this is getting really
interesting I'm very excited to see
where this game goes it looks like it
has a lot of potential but remember the
other episodes aren't released yet
they're being released slowly so I'll
support the developers in whatever way
you can I don't even think they have
donation page up they're just going at
it whole hog so good for them so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
ah
ah
well in this place I could
Oh
by
in the dark
my god